yeah uh I mean you seem like or I know
that you are an extremely practical uh
practical player and one of your
strengths is that you can sort of
squeeze positions and get something out
of positions that are very uh yeah
Jewish and very dry and then I know that
you play you play a lot online like you
play a lot of bullet you play a lot of
very uh
consciously stupid openings like the
Greek or some boom cloud or some very
very dubious stuff just to
uh just to train your yourself how do
you think this has affected you is it
very uh is it useful to play
let's say very bad openings and then put
yourself in a bad position and just
fight in order to become a better
fighter and yeah has this affected you
in any way you think I think that can be
can be useful so I'm not a very good
I'm not a very good Defender
in general
[Music]
like well I mean I can defend certain
positions but
just like just defending
uh
like passive positions and so on I'm not
very
I'm not very good uh so I mean those
things are mainly for fun not for any
training
uh training purposes but yeah in terms
of training yeah I I guess it could be
I guess it could be useful especially
like not I mean not necessarily playing
the Greek or whatever but to like get so
used to extricating yourself from
these sort of crime positions that can
be
can be be useful because a lot of people
like including Meats sometimes it's like
ah decision sucks what am I good there
what am I gonna do now
um
and uh
yeah
actually to enlarge on this let's say
playing bullet online of glitch where do
you rate that on the scale from being
harmful to being entertainment to being
useful is personal or how is it yeah I
don't know if bullets is useful uh I
think Blitz is 100 useful
um
Blitz devops
um develops instincts
um
really like
chess is developing more
the more
to be played online and like a lot of
the most important tournaments now are
as are rapid so rapid is basically rapid
is not a thing
rapid is a hybrid between
um
between classical and bullets so that
was sorry no bullet uh blitz so
basically like the two things that you
should be doing like I don't think a lot
of people train rapid at all like the
things you should be trading for our
classical
outlets in
in in that sense
um so like when you when you start out
in in a rapid game you try to play
more or less the same way as you would
and In classical just or at least I I do
and then eventually you know there's uh
there's a face at the end where which
resemble resemble students
but
yeah I think
[Music]
I think like Blitz is useful
um
I think
anybody like any coaches
trying to dissuade you from
from Android lenses is doing you a
disservice uh really because it's uh
it's very good for your